all right so is so I'm gonna count the
people who fall asleep I'll remember you
forever of course I'm joking
all right so but to try to I want to try
to I mean this is going to be less way
less intense than the first talk okay
I'm going to try to bring it down into
the level of practical reality I as you
know most of you maybe some of you don't
know I am an I am an icon Carver and
that's my mostly my job and I also do
this is sneaking but most of mostly my
job is to make images and to make
objects for the church for individuals
and so you're going to see a few of my
objects as we go through this
presentation we show a few things that
I'm working on and one of the things
that we're trying to do is to recapture
a vision of art which would be fuller
which would be more encompassing of
reality more aware of what it means to
act in the world what is exactly the
power that we have as human beings made
in the image of God in the way that
father talked about how is it that we
can understand that it's very
fascinating because yesterday I was at
the at the the Museum the fine arts
museum and I had forgotten I don't know
why I'd forgotten I should have known
this but one of the people that has
actually helped me to understand
Christian art in a more traditionally
Christian way is this man ananda
coomaraswamy he's not a Christian he
would single ease you know in East Asia
but he was the curator of the Boston
Museum here in the 1920s I think and
he's actually responsible for their East
Asia collection
and he's responsible for just the whole
study of the East Asian art of Asian art
in America is basically due to this guy
and sometimes that the funny thing is
that sometimes you need someone from the
outside to point out to you your
precious thing because you can't see it
anymore you've forgotten it or whatever
and and coomaraswamy
try to bring back the notion of art the
way that the medievals understood it the
way that the traditional Christians
understood it and art even in Latin the
word art means well fitted together
something which is well put together and
so when we we think about art today we
think of art as objects right so that's
art this is not art all of that type of
attitude we go to a museum to see art
you know we buy art put it up on our
walls that is not at all the traditional
way of understanding art coomaraswamy
always said the art remains in the
artist that is art is the capacity that
a person has an artisan to fit things
well together and in the image of what
father told us this morning that is how
you could understand the human the role
of the human being in with others is to
have the capacity to fit things well
together that is what we have been given
as a capacity and that is let's say how
we're what we're called to do and when
things are well fitted together
you know you can imagine this as an
image even of the body of the church
that's exactly how st. Paul describes
the church as the body well fitted
together in love that is
that is how communion exists that is how
the world becomes peace all of these
things is when things are well fitted
together when things are all in their
proper place and are all brought
together in love and that is ultimately
what the artist can do and when we think
about it that way we think we realize
that anybody can be an artist
kamaswami has the great quote he says
right the artist is not a special kind
of man but every man is a special kind
of artist that is that all the things
that we do even in the ancient world
when we talk about you know the art of
cheese-making or the art of rhetoric or
the art of this and the art of that this
is what I'm trying to get back to is the
the capacity to fit to fit things well
together and so if you're a you know if
you're you care anything if you're a
baker you can make you can put together
a cake in a beautiful manner right you
can bring the elements together and
reveal the cake to us and that that
action it doesn't only happen in the
thing it also happens in the people who
participate in that thing so if I'm
making a good cake I'm not just making
it for it to be a good cake right what
does it imply for it to be a good cake
it implies that I'm also pulling you
into my cake right it's not just the
cake you are part of my cake because
you're the ones who are going to eat it
and you're the ones who are going to
recognize that I am a good artist as I
bring this cake together right so the
the the artisan the good artist is
pulling the material things together
revealing the essence
something but he's he's inevitably also
doing that in a community it's a
participative act as you like I said as
you eat the cake or as you listen to my
speech as you read my letter as you
whatever it is that I'm making
it's a pulling in of people as well
that's really really it's so important
to understand because we have been
ruined in the modern world to think that
the ultimate you know the ultimate
cultural experience is this is to all go
to a concert and all sit nicely and to
and to look at someone who's playing
music and to listen carefully and to go
to a museum to stand in a museum and
look at things you know that used to be
somewhere and appreciate the art week we
think now there's nothing wrong with
doing that I was at the museum yesterday
there's nothing wrong with doing that
but there is something wrong with
believing that that is the highest form
of culture that the highest form of
culture is going into a museum and
seeing these objects that are ripped out
of their context you know I always say
that museums are cemeteries for objects
it's like they're all dead all these
things are dead there they used to be
part of something part of someone's life
and now they're all and they're all
cataloged you know like you go to these
museums and cities white-walled with
objects it's so pretty
Oh anyways it's fine it's fine go to
going to museums is fine but it's mostly
to help you understand that this is not
that's not the highest form of
participation or that's not the highest
form of culture right this this is the
highest form of culture a procession a
parade a folk dance right church service
why why is it a higher form of culture
because it's it's participative it's not
it's just like you know what I talked
about the problem of the Bible as being
this thing that you just sit there and
you read and it's out there and you
analyze it as if it's something outside
of you we've somehow created the same
problem with culture you'll hear people
say that you consume culture you ever
heard that my goodness well we do right
we watch Netflix we go to the movies
it's fine like I said there's nothing
wrong with that but entertainment is not
the highest form of art entertainment is
not the highest form of culture
participation is the highest form of
culture and so now so how do we how do
we do this I want you to read you just
one little quote from Martin Heidegger
if you want to also understand this this
vision of art yeah
Heidegger wrote a little text called the
questions concerning technology it's a
great little text and he used the word
technology but in the ancient world that
the word for for technology and the word
for art as we understand it today it was
just the same the word techne it's just
we know what I talked about how applied
knowledge well whether you apply it to
making a painting whether you apply it
to building a cart it's both art there
is no the weird difference that we've
created between art and technology and
the weird difference we've created
between high art and popular art all of
these distinctions are are extremely
nefarious for our understanding of how
to participate in reality and these are
some of the things that we're trying to
break down the solution that we're
proposing I'm going to show you some
artists myself and other artists that
are trying to do this is we are trying
to break down the very presupposition of
art the the proposition of this pattern
that I'm telling you about the
proposition in a way of sacred art in
its understanding as participative art
it's the right now it's the most radical
thing you can do
I'm going to show you some of the things
and I'm going to encourage some of the
artists to think because we always need
more people to get involved in this
so Heidegger talks about how technique
or art is a form of truth a form of
unveiling and he says whoever builds a
house or a ship or forges the
sacrificial chalice reveals what is to
be brought forth okay so it's an act of
revealing this revealing gathers
together in advance the aspect and the
matter of the ship or the housing right
your house at first is not a house it's
two things it's a plan and it's a bunch
of pieces of wood so you have something
invisible pattern then you have a bunch
of stuff and what you want to do so you
want to connect those two together so it
gathers in advance the aspect on the
matter of the ship or house with the
view to the finished thing envisioned as
completed thus what is decisive in
technique does not lie at all in making
and manipulating nor in the using of
means and here he is talking directly at
the the Marxist and also this kind of
the vision of technology as production
right so that's not the point but it's
rather this the revealing of the thing
that is being brought together right and
it is as revealing and not as
manufacturing that Tecna is a bringing
forth so when we talked about this idea
of expressing that I mentioned something
a little bit about that before when I
said you know I don't think the purpose
of the artist is to express himself and
I really really think that I think the
purpose of the artist is to express the
thing that he's expressing right to
express the cake express an image
express ultimately to express the peace
of God to express the communion of the
saints
these are the things that we're
expressing much more than myself myself
is gonna get in there somewhere but I
can't totally keep it in myself it's
gonna happen but that's not my point
that's not the purpose of what I'm doing
right and so one of the things so
there's a few of us a group of us and
there to start to introduce you to them
a few years ago in 2012 and it's funny
because everybody here all these people
know father Patrick or Roark it seems a
lot of the priests here know him he he
is one of the people who founded this
journal and it's a bunch of us who were
trying to break down this problem and
trying to bring back the idea of sacred
art but the reason why we want to bring
back the idea of sacred art is not just
sacred art we want to get the highest
highest possible so what's the highest
thing you can express yeah not directly
indirectly let's say Express the glory
of God that's the highest thing that's
the highest thing you can celebrate in
art is God let's say it that way the
highest thing you can celebrate in art
is God that's the top the highest form
of art is liturgical art because it is
in the service in the worship in the
communion of all those who are
worshiping God and so it has to start it
has to start there and that's what we're
trying to do trying to re capture Reax
reinvigorate the sacred art but what
you're going to see is that it we also
believe that once that happens and I
talked about going up to the top and
then filling up the world that's but you
have to get to that you have to to fix
the top thing first and then the rest is
going to flow out of that so this is a a
friend of mine his name is Andrew Gould
he's in architect in Charleston I would
encourage that you check him out he is
becoming quite famous in
in the recent months there's a book
written about him just last year
published by Yale by Yale on
it's called Charleston fancy and it
talks about these architects who are
trying to rethink the city and to
rethink urban urban areas and that's
where we have to start you know as a
carver you know and as someone who draws
and paints and write stories I still
have to acknowledge that the highest art
is architecture it is the most important
art in terms of human fabrication
because and it's so important that we
forget it that's how important it is
it's so important that we don't realize
that architecture defines the very
spaces of our life it defines what we
consider inside would we consider
outside it defines the basic categories
of human existence are defined by
architecture right this just the idea of
inside and outside is one of the most
basic structures of all human thinking
and architecture is making you
participate in that
it's the highest form of art because
it's also participative it's the most
participative you live inside these
buildings you worship in these buildings
you work in these buildings it's the
very frame of your world so you go into
a building and you look at a painting on
the wall and that's fine but you
couldn't do that without the building
and so the degrade the degrading of
architecture is one of the biggest
scandals way bigger than Picasso stuff
or Marcel Duchamp ready-mades or
whatever it is in surrealist came up
with the degrading of architecture the
strip malls the the the horrible urban
planning the highways the the electric
wires going above are are our streets
that is the that is the cancer of the
modern world way more than any any bad
concert that you can attend because it
is the very very frame of our existence
so that's what that's what
to be fixed first and so andrew has
mastered he has mastered Byzantine
architecture also Western medieval
architecture gothic but all been then
all Western architecture really so he
makes churches this is his Church in
Charleston he's made several churches if
you ever in Charleston it's really one
of the most beautiful places I think in
America in this church it's very simple
but it's it's it's very powerful but he
also write he also makes houses but if
you really want to see my friend Andrew
Gould shine you have to visit the beer
store it's the most magical place that
you'll ever be because it really looks
like a beer store he has he has actually
manifested the essence of the beer store
and so it's this amazing timber-frame
building and you know with turned
shelves and you know post architecture
and there's a skylight and an opening in
the floor and people go in there and
they just going in to buy beer and they
don't want to leave this just wanting to
stay there and so there's something
right there's something of actually
Byzantine architecture in this thing
right shirt obviously no one could
confuse this for a church but he's got
gotten a little bit of something a
little bit of something which makes a
space special and he's adapted it to a
beer store right and so he has the most
beautiful beer store in America so
Andrew and I we also work together here
it is a shrine that we did for the holy
Russian family and you can see the
reliquary I carved the icon in the
reliquary
here's one here's a project we worked on
together as well it's a large carving of
Saint Michel killing the dragon with
stone inserts there's no paint on this
all the colors are stones and the gold
is gold leaf so what we're trying to do
is we're trying to so if you look at
this image for example on the one hand
it looks like something that could have
been made I don't know and like 1,200 or
something but nothing like this was ever
made in the year 1200 there's actually
this is actually completely 8 the
technique the use of the materials the
way that the dragon is made is actually
not at all something you could have seen
in the 12th century but it's rather to
try to make something which looks
timeless makes something which looks as
if it could have been made a thousand
years ago but it was made today it's not
a copy of something that was made a
thousand years ago that is in the state
that a lot of and say a lot of
iconographer is even today make is they
do just want to make copies of the old
time it's like you can do that but you
also want to actually master the
language rather than just make copies if
you master the language you can make new
objects that don't that aren't just
copies but that look as if you'd seen
them before this is a this is a Crozier
that I made for the Catholic Archbishop
of Montreal and with Andrew as well I'm
just showing you things I made with
Andrew because I wanted you to see a
little bit of this teamwork that we're
trying to develop this is a gospel cover
that is here in Boston at the at the OCA
Cathedral in Boston
so this is what this is what I'm doing
most of the time that's what I'm doing
but sometimes people look at what I'm
doing and they don't understand and I am
just I can see why they'd understand
because I'm also doing this like I'm
doing I'm also making t-shirts
iPhone cases and t-shirts and eggs why
why am i doing that because there's
nothing wrong with t-shirts who thinks
just something wrong with t-shirts it's
really yeah it's really important it's
really important to understand this we
have we we really have this weird
elitist thing about art this weird
elitist vision of art that we think that
art is this precious thing in museums
that art is this just this high thing
that we look at and that we don't
participate in it's like no I want you
to wear our t-shirt that's participate -
I love it I think it's great I'm not
going to put my icon on the t-shirt
right I'm going to I'm going to create
something for the t-shirt and one of the
some of the images that I tend to use
our images of protection so a Griffin
you have an angel you have Alexander the
Great these outer images those are the
ones that I tend to use for for for
t-shirts but all based on the
understanding that I gain from the
making the liturgical art that is if if
you're gonna wear if you're gonna wear a
t-shirt because you are I might as well
wear a t-shirt that is connected somehow
to something higher and I also like I
really mock I kind of kind of mocking
the entertainment world but there's
nothing wrong with entertainment I don't
think there's anything wrong with
entertainment if you go to my my youtube
channel you'll see that I interpret
movies I do all that stuff
there's nothing wrong with these things
it's only about things being in their
proper place right like if a priest went
into the altar wearing one of my
t-shirts I would physically eject them
if I could write a you know it's not
it's it's only about things being in the
right place in the world when once you
start to think in hierarchies then a lot
of things start to break in your mind so
one of the things I'm doing is I'm
actually I'm writing a comic book I'm
making a comic book it's based on the
story of Saint Christopher a very very
loose retelling of the story of Saint
Christopher and I took all like I looked
at popular culture and I saw the kind of
things that were there and I said we
have that right we have a lot of weird
things in the Bible there's a lot of
weird things in the Bible
I said why not write a story that takes
all the weird things in the Bible and
all the weird things in our tradition
they just put them in one story and then
when people read it at first they think
art is going to be great because it's
going to be so subversive but then in
the end it actually not subversive it
turns it all back and so in this story
saying Christopher is a dog headed man
there's st. Simeon the skylight who is
on his Pole there are dragons and Giants
and monsters and the Leviathan all the
crazy stuff the Bible was all in this
one story so his here's the first
appearance of Saint Christopher if you
don't know the story of synchro's ever I
won't tell it now but you can you can
look it up on my youtube channel and
it's the same even with my speaking I
tried to do the same like I so I have if
you if you go to my YouTube channel if
you come here sometimes I talk about try
to talk about the highest things try to
to help people understand the power of
the gospel the beauty and scripture the
beauty our tradition the beauty in the
icons but I think the whole world lays
itself out in this pattern there's no
exception everything is in this pattern
nothing is outside of the way that the
logos manifests itself in the world so
you can talk about anything so there you
go so I've got this stuff to talk about
Rudolph talked about this weird thing
that happened this ice cream licking
challenge that happened in in the u.s.
meaning of goblins and words and imps
all these things have meaning if they
didn't have meaning they wouldn't exist
we can talk about it but I wouldn't want
someone talking about that in the altar
right it's just all about it's all about
place all right
and some of the people that worked with
us to develop the Orthodox Arsenal they
have started a new organization I was
sadly not able to go to their first
meeting which was a month ago about a
month ago but I would suggest that you
check them out they're called artifact
and what they want to do is exactly what
I talked about they want to help people
rediscover the art as participation and
so they are organizing events that are
going to organize trainings they're
going to also have publications which
are going to try to bring back so if you
look at their description they say it
says liturgy visual arts music
literature architecture storytelling
craft and conviviality anything oh
that's odd how did that if you if you
listened to it I said you'll understand
how you can't have all of these things
should bring conviviality but that's
what the point of the whole the whole
thing all of this should bring communion
all of this should bring togetherness
that's what art is actually for right so
that when if I make something powerful
and you recognize it and you participate
in it then we are linked together and so
they they are organizing singing they're
teaching classes on how to receive
people things that we used to do but no
one does anymore how to receive people
how to organize an event a party at your
house how do you receive people how can
you do that in a way that will encourage
people to come together that's an art
it's not arbitrary you know how to set a
table you think that we knew these
things but don't knows these things
anymore our grandparents did it's all
gone and so trying to read to rekindle
this these skills that we used to have
that are slowly dying you know this the
the skill of singing together singing
folk songs telling stories telling folk
stories telling you know telling your
own story how do you tell the story so
that it's it so that it's gripping is
that it's useful for the person you're
telling the story to
one of the people involved in this you
can see him actually probably won't be
able to see him it's in that picture his
name is Nicholas Kotar and he's an
author also he's an he's an Orthodox
deacon
he's at now I'm gonna forget the name
he's in Jordan Villette the Russian
seminary there and he's writing novels
his novels have nothing Christian in
them it doesn't talk about Jesus in his
novels doesn't talk about you know the
church or anything but his works are
some of the most Christian works that
I've ever read because that is where
once you understand the pattern once
you're inside the pattern once you
understand that this these this pattern
that I told you about about the garden
and the fall and this this this descent
and this this ascent all of these
patterns as the patterns of reality then
you can participate in all kinds of ways
you can write stories you can see that
the fairy tales also have the same
pattern you can see Christ in fairy
tales you can see Christ in the ancient
myths you can see Christ in movies you
can see Christ Christ is the good thing
hidden in all even the bad things he's
hiding in there doesn't mean that
everything's good obviously not a lot of
things that's a lot of trash out there
but there's there's Christ as that which
is good which is hiding and everything
which makes it exist and so just like
talking for example if you read Lord of
the Rings you won't there's nothing
Christian about Lord of the Rings right
so why is it that all Christians
resonate with Lord of the Rings so much
why is it that all the Christians a lot
of Orthodox people's - for some reason
really like to order the Rings really
love Lord of the Rings it's because it's
showing you this powerful pattern of
reality in a different language and this
and you and the excitement you have is
that although it's in the language that
is completely different from that of
Scripture you can still see that it's
showing you that story even though it's
different and that I think is ultimately
that I think ultimately is what artists
can be what artists can do is to help
people see artists are kind of like
magicians artists in that because we can
help people see get that click because
you know we have this boring world we
have this kind of everyday life and that
what the artist can do is by gathering
things together by enacting the creative
act by by being you know an image of God
in this bringing together and showing
the essence of something you can wake
something up in someone kind of wake up
their news using technical words here
but you can kind of wake up their
spiritual intuition so that they realize
that the world is not dark at hiding
behind all this dark gray stuff they're
all the fairies are still there and all
the all the angels are there and
everything is all there behind you just
have to help people kind of see through
the the-the-the glum the glum strip
malls and all that stuff so that is my
encouragement for for artists not sure
that I treated what people expected me
to treat so if you have any questions on
art whatsoever we're good I think I'll
have some time to do that
I really enjoy and a lot of now people
see past things like ask their suffering
to see like what's the real meaning
behind stuff
oh so I was going to ask you about like
art when you're making heart so like for
me as a therapist that's my heart I'm
making a pen doing arm so I'm doing
therapy and somebody I'm talking about
myself at some point and I started a lot
of transference right like I feel upset
I get angry hmm
right so like when you're doing art like
do you feel like the Pentagon
you get like different messages or
different like feelings or like free
like I know it's kind of a complex one
but it's like um whole feelings things
is really complicated because there's a
there's an there's an aspect of reality
okay let's so put it this way there's an
aspect of reality which is that which is
just objective in the sense that it
actually has nothing to do with me
and there's an aspect of reality which
also includes that say my own personal
spiritual path let's say so a good way
to understand it is if you have a priest
in the church and he baptized you and
then you find out later that the priest
was a crook and the priest was cheating
on his wife or whatever that doesn't
invalidate the sacraments the sacraments
are valid doesn't matter the priest was
an idiot
okay and there's an aspect to art which
is like that too which is there are
moments in my let's say practice of
carving icons where I am I just feel
like I am totally connected and that you
know I'm in tune and that I'm in
communion with the saint that I'm
representing and that I'm in communion
with the person who is asking me to make
the saint that I somehow feel like I'm
making this image for them and that it's
going to participate in their spiritual
life and I'm kind of I can be aware of
all of this as I'm doing it and you know
I saw there's it can really be a short
of very a little Epiphany let's say but
the weird thing about it that that
doesn't mean that those are going to be
the best icons that I make there are
some times when it's the opposite where
I'm fighting with my wife or I have
financial problems and I'm like
my mind is just turning and I'm not not
at all in a good place virtually but and
then someone will look at my cut and say
oh there's so much Grace and that I kind
of like that's not me like does that
mean and so I think that I think that
it's both I think that it depends I
think we're vehicles we can be vehicles
for for God's God's grace even though
we're not there and then we thank God
for all the moments that we can and we
can really participate in that in that
process so
with I love here your real about
architecture
because one of the things
yeah and scribbles yeah so how do we do
it yeah
yeah I mean no I yeah you're right your
your question is the rest question it's
a great question I think that I think
that the the best version of
Christianity that's what it's supposed
to be right the best version of
Christianity is supposed to be that
hierarchy is always that which is above
loves that which is below and that which
is below submits to that which is above
but those two things have to cross each
other and so and so in the in the
structure of the church for example
that's what we see and so the priest
although the priest is you know is up
there and he's up there and the
hierarchy and the bishop is up there in
the hierarchy there's a very special
there's a very real concrete way in
which the priest is also supposed to
serve the people but he's there also to
serve his the people who come and if he
listens to their confession he he
pastors them he marries them me so it's
not it's so it's not just an authority
in the sense of this you know of this
top-down thing but it's rather this
exchange of love and authority that that
will give that world now obviously there
you might say and maybe it would be true
that it's never happened completely and
there's always been a no it kind of it's
always kind of goes up and down and
manifests one more or the other but I do
think that that that is what
Christianity is supposed to be and I
think that I think that the church
architecture and the liturgy represents
that because for example in the Orthodox
tradition we we can't have a priest who
says the the mass alone there has to be
a men if there's no a men
there's no liturgy if there's no yes
there's no there's no Annunciation the
mother of God doesn't say yes there's no
renunciation there's no
carnation right and so that is the you
know when we talk about the
call-and-response father talked a little
bit about that in terms of antipodal
singing that's also part of it there's
this we still have it now in the
procurement islands and all this where
it's like there's this call in this
response and it's this this back and
forth between the the authority and the
people are are dancing together in this
this communal manner so I think that
that's the that's the answer but like I
said doesn't mean that it happens a lot
in the New Jerusalem
yeah of course
having Saint Christopher with a dog
that's fantastic yeah so you're not
going all imagination
no I think I think that it's just about
its I hate to say its hierarchy again
but there's minute so it's argue again
it's just about having things in service
of other things you know so our human
capacity is the imagination included is
something which can be put to the
service of God and manifests higher
things
bori or it can also be prideful and want
to to show its own genius and to show
its own capacity to be smart and to be
witty you know and so it just really
just depends on how it's used on how
it's with which way it's directed that's
what I would say yeah no I well okay so
this is this is a the good example would
be a horror movies right so I don't
think you should watch more movies I
don't think anybody should watch horror
movies but I think that horror movies
are an expression of a very deep truth
even though I don't think you should
watch them and and I think a lot of
people have actually understood that
recently in the past 20 years people
have actually understood that that
horror movies despite their grotesque
and disgusting appeal to our very base
senses are actually morality tales that
they that they actually follow a
structure of fallen punishment and
that's actually how the the horror movie
sets itself up and think about upside
down stories is that upside down I like
again I don't think we should indulge in
upside down stories but we they're
upside down for a reason if you still
recognize them as upside down you're
already a not so bad because you know
that they're upside down and that they
should be right-side up
it's like if you recognize something
which is making fun of something else if
you recognize it as making fun of the
other thing then you're already not
completely lost because you're you know
you're putting something if you put
something upside down and you say it's
upside down
know what it looks like to be right that
up does that make sense
right so so even in the even in the most
like even in the most like heavy-metal
satanic you know all that stuff it's
like if you look at their aesthetic and
you look at what they're saying if you
understand them as being upside down it
makes total sense they're actually
embodying the upside down in like you
want to give them a prize like you're
actually you're actually embodying the
upside down quite well like then I can
tell them my pair engineers you want to
see what it looks like there's right
there that's what it looks like don't do
that
[Laughter]
yeah exactly of course hair is it can
useful yeah
was simply share the gospel - there are
no I don't think that I mean explicitly
like evangelize no I don't think that's
necessary I think that especially right
now also the art that does that is
usually pretty bad most of it a lot of
the movies like the Christian movies
they're so bad
they're so bad so it depends you can do
it by explicitly referencing God but it
has to be part of a coherent narrative
right if you you can reference God
directly if if the story is related to
that if that's what the story is about
but you you don't necessarily if it's
not then you don't have to and when I
talk about like when I talk about art
and if your your painting beautiful
borders in the church those beautiful
borders are not explicitly managed this
is showing you they're not explicitly
showing you Christ even in the church
and if I put a if I put a Griffin on the
outside of the church or on the
iconostasis like that Griffin is not
directly showing us Christ it's it's
like there's a hierarchy and depending
in which place it is I think that a lot
of fairytales and a lot of folktales are
closer to showing us Christ and a lot of
the Christian novels and and because
they actually embody the pattern in a
very organic and understood manner so no
I don't I don't think so but you can you
know
she said do we need to do you think that
Christian audition should explicitly
reference Christ in their art in order
to be Christian artists and my answer
was no not necessarily it just depends
what you're doing but if you can in if
you want it like a good if you read some
of the Russian novelist for that we're
talking about novels like if you read
Dostoyevsky like yeah my goodness I mean
he does it with supreme excellence I
mean he can write a story where you know
there is direct reference to Jesus
Christ and direct reference to the
mystery and talking about the
Incarnation and talking about the
problem of evil and all that and he does
it like that
there's no criticism but not everybody
can do that you know not everybody does
that - yeah yep
Jesus Christ then you should show
describe
[Music]
I think I the way that I could I could
answer that is that the the way that the
church works is that the church the
church receives the tradition and the
church says yes to a tradition and in
the beginning of the of the church there
was actually several ways of
representing Christ there were really -
there was one which was to show Christ
as a kind of Apollo figure like curly
hair and kind of Adonis looking figure
and then there was a tradition to show
him looking like a Nazarene which is and
he's this directly described by Eusebius
as this idea of looking like a Nazarene
which is long beard long hair and that's
the tradition that was received and
accepted by the church and so now when
we show Christ we show him in that
manner from I would say the first
tradition persisted a few centuries but
for sure I would say by the seventh
eighth century it was pretty much
everywhere in the world
Christ is represented the same way from
Spain to Syria to Ireland to wherever
Christ was represented with having a
beard longest hair you know wearing two
vestments when investment upon top and
were investment underneath and that
really became kind of the universal
tradition until until maybe the
Renaissance yeah there are images like
there it's crazy like their images from
no Syrian images from the 4th 5th
century there's that famous image in the
6th century the the image of Christ at
Sinai you ever seen it you can see when
one of eyes kind of Christ sighs it's
kind of looking to the side that image
was isolated like it was in cyan I saw
like everybody could see it but you see
an image from the 14th century in
Constantinople and it looks like they
copied that image like how did that
happen it means that there was a
language there was a language that was
preserved and was transmitted and this
image of Christ is the one that was
received by the church
so how we do represent him yeah yeah I
don't know if that's how Christ is
described in Scripture I know I don't I
don't know which which which you're
which aspect which where you're
referring to when you say that but I
think that yeah I don't know this is
that we should be looking right so if I
got God what somebody wants to colonize
people hmm I'm saying that whoa
I I think that the question let's say
but you have to understand it like the
idea that the idea that Christ is is
white it's very odd it's just an odd way
just not the way the ancients thought
they just didn't think in those
categories so it's a very modern problem
to think like that Jesus was white
already like for the Romans I mean Jesus
was a Jew he wasn't a Roman he looked
like he looked Syrian if you look at the
images of Christ the early images he
looked like a kind of Syrian guy if you
and and people would just they didn't
just didn't think about that if you go
to Ethiopia and you look at Ethiopian
traditions of representations of Christ
like they're pigment is darker than the
pigments that are used by by Byzantines
or by Northern Europeans and that's fine
it's not a problem but it's not it's
also not an issue for the Christians
like it's a modern issue it's not an
ancient issue it's something that comes
with modern politics and modern kind of
problems that we that are real I'm not
saying they're that they're
real problems they're real but it's just
not the categories that were used by the
ancient people they just didn't think in
those terms it's always see it yeah
timeless yeah well is the longer it
lasts the better it is right in terms of
term and longer glass in terms the
longer you can recognize reality in it
it means it's coming closer to something
you know because it says that's just for
art it's the same for everything right
it's the same it's like if you if you
make a shirt and you can wear that shirt
for one season and then if you wear next
season you look like a complete idiot
because it's the fashion is gone then
you've missed the major pattern might
have rode this extreme kind of
excitement of the of the you know the
titillating of the new but you've missed
the basic pattern so you can create
something which was still recognized as
having value in 100 years and means
you're closer to something real that
makes sense yeah
when we talk about patterns of reality
and these things we're finding
we're spoiled by saying but there's a
difference
nature in convention and that we find
this pattern again and again in
convention but that's just because
necessarily reality that there's no
reason to think that
our desire for this sourcing which might
be best expressed by the Christian story
corresponds to something that you could
actually find it anyway well that whole
idea of convention is really funny the
concepts how people come to that concept
like where does the convention come from
and if you're if you're a naturalist
like a real naturalist and you think
that everything is explained out of
these naturalistic patterns then you
can't you can't stand outside of the
pattern and then declare a convention
that's silly how can you stand outside
of the pattern are you in the pattern or
not but if you're in the natural world
then you can't just say these are just
convention it's like they're not just
conventions no more than I don't know
like no more than peacocks putting up
their tails are just conventions these
there are things that happened now look
at try to understand how they happen in
and what pattern they happen and then
that will usually get rid of your
problem a private way one of the
problems of a lot of the naturalist is
that they they somehow still can't apply
their thing to themselves once you flip
that back it's really interesting by the
way once you flip it back once you take
the scientific perception and you
actually turn it back on the human on
yourself then things get really wobbly
really fast things start to get very
strange and what comes out of it ends up
looking more like a traditional
worldview then that kind of kind of
that's a kind of usual scientific
worldview where they're scientists
somehow stands above the world for
somehow it doesn't is not in phenomena
and can analyze it without being in it
like no you can't do that you're in
phenomena too it starts to turn so that
to me that question is meaningless it's
totally meaningless when someone says
it's just convention it's like okay well
why do we have those conventions
let's keep pressing just so that society
would work better yes all right so
Society would work but why do you want
to decide you to work better because
then we'll then will last longer and
will well [ __ ] yes all right so is it
still just a convention
if it actually provides the pattern by
which you do better it's not just a
convention it's the way that you it's a
pattern by which you live that makes you
live better life
anyways that's why I thought I think
we're done huh all right guys you guys
have been I mean I've asked your
attention from this morning until like 3
o'clock in the afternoon so you guys
have been amazing like a whole school
day so thanks for thanks for coming and
paying attention I appreciate it
[Applause]